pour on vous retrouve en direct de
Bruxelles au siège de l'OTAN et c'est là
donc que la Finlande fait ses premiers
pas
en effet la Finlande fait ses premiers
pas et le drapeau finlandais
IC ici dans la cour d'honneur du
quartier général de l'OTAN ici à
Bruxelles juste derrière moi c'est un
moment évidemment très symbolique voir
historique selon le secrétaire général
de l'OTAN historique d'abord pour la
Finlande qui met fin à plus de 30 ans de
non alignement militaire et qui va
bénéficier vous l'avez dit de la
protection de l'article 5 du Traité de
l'Atlantique Nord selon lequel si l'un
des membres de l'Alliance est attaqué
c'est comme si tous les membres de
l'OTAN étaient attaqué mais c'est aussi
pour l'Alliance elle-même une évolution
stratégique très importante puisqu'il y
avec l'adhésion de la Finlande des biens
elle hérite déjà d'une armée très
puissante et puis elle double sa
frontière avec la Russie ce qui lui
permet et bien de consolider
considérablement son flanc nord-est et
puis c'est la preuve de la revigoration
de l'OTAN cette organisation que
beaucoup qualifiait de moribond il y a
encore quelques temps mais qui se
renforcent depuis le début de la guerre
en Ukraine la Russie qui voulait moins
de temps mais c'est tout le contraire
qui est en train de se passer à dit en
substance yenstoltenberg hier le
secrétaire général de l'OTAN alors
l'adhésion de la Finlande c'est
évidemment un revers pour Moscou qui a
promis des contre-mesures notamment si
les forces d'un autre membre de l'OTAN
venait à se déployer sur le sol
finlandais merci pour ces précisions
Alix le bourdon de futur Bruxelles la